hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live Mitglieder einer kriminellen
Vereinigung abschieben auch wenn sie
selbst nicht für eine Straftat
verurteilt worden sind das schlägt
Innenministerin Phaser vor demnach soll
es wohl also reichen ein Mitglied in
einem Kriminellen Clan oder einer
ähnlichen Vereinigung zu sein um das
Aufenthaltsrecht in Deutschland zu
verlieren das Innenministerium hat
diesen Vorschlag in ein
Diskussionspapier geschrieben und das
wird jetzt den Ländern und Kommunen
vorgelegt die sollen darüber abstimmen
pRO ASYL hat Kritik geäußert unter
anderem hält diesen Vorschlag für
gefährlich spricht von Wiedereinführung
der rippenhaft schauen wir mal gemeinsam
in das Papier denn hier steht es ich
habe diesen Punkt hier markiert und zwar
an dieser Stelle können wir es lesen
diese knüpft über den Straftat bestand
das Strafgesetzbuch 129 Paragraph 129
Bildung krimineller Vereinigung an die
Angehörigkeit zu einer solchen
Gemeinschaft an und ist unabhängig von
einer strafrechtlichen
Beurteilung hier können wir es also
lesen was meint ihr ist das eine gute
Idee um Clan Kriminalität in den Griff
zu bekommen oder ist das nicht
verhältnismäßig ist das unrealistisch
darum soll es heute bei uns gehen das
wollen wir mit euch diskutieren ihr
könnt es hier sehen also Clan
Kriminalität leichter abschieben dass es
unser Thema und ihr könnt Fragen stellen
direkt im Stream oder per Mail
kommentiert live mit ich habe einen Gast
jetzt sogar heute auch bei mir im Studio
bei mir ist Dirk hecklohn er ist
Vorsitzender des Bundes Deutscher
Kriminalbeamter er hat selbst jahrelang
in Hessen in der organisierten
Kriminalität ermittelt er ist heute bei
uns schön dass Sie da sind hallo
Sie haben von dem Vorschlag gelesen von
dem Vorschlag gehört die Ursprungsidee
die entstand wohl auf einem Bund Länder
treffen im Mai also Frau Faser das
Innenministerium hat den Vorschlag sich
jetzt zu eigen gemacht aber der ist
schon auch ein bisschen länger steht
hier im Raum was halten Sie davon
also zunächst mal müssen wir in dieses
Papier reingucken das ist entstanden im
Rahmen der das Treffens der
Regierungschefin und Chefs mit dem
Bundeskanzler also die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz da ging es
eigentlich nur um also nur da ging es um
Problematiken bei der abschiebungspraxis
in Deutschland und das bezog sich nicht
auf klaren Kriminalität unter anderem
sondern auch auf viele andere Felder der
Kriminalität des kriminalitätsgeschehens
rund um Menschen die hier eben einen
entsprechenden Aufenthaltsstatus haben
und daraus resultierend hat Frau Feser
offensichtlich dann diese Forderungen
entworfen es ist also letztlich eine
Reaktion der auf das was im
Koalitionsvertrag schon drin steht dass
die Bundesregierung eben die Bekämpfung
der organisierten Kriminalität aber auch
hier insbesondere der klaren
Kriminalität angehen will das ist
grundsätzlich zu begrüßen also wir als
Bund Deutscher Kriminalbeamter begrüßen
jegliche Aktivitäten die dazu führen
dass wir das Thema Clan Kriminalität
endlich in Deutschland so angehen dass
wir hier nachhaltig
Bekämpfungsstrategien entwickeln auf der
anderen Seite muss man aber sagen dass
dieser Vorschlag natürlich noch genau
geprüft werden muss und dass wir eben
sehen müssen was ist damit genau gemeint
und ich hoffe dass wir darüber heute
Abend auch sprechen können mit
Sicherheit aber kurz auch noch mal
nachgefragt weil selbst aus den Reihen
der Partei von Frau fehrser aus der SPD
selbst aus den eigenen Reihen gibt es
Kritik der Vorsitzende der
Arbeitsgemeinschaft Migration und
Vielfalt in der SPD der twittert auch
nun Sippenhaft sehen sie da also gar
keine Problematik wenn es jetzt heißt
pauschal abschieben also wir müssen hier
unterscheiden es geht hier nicht darum
etwas mit einer Abschiebung zu
kommentieren was in irgendeiner Form mit
einer genetischen Linie oder sowas zu
tun hat da sind wir Gott sei Dank und
hoffentlich weiterhin auch weit von
entfernt in Deutschland also hier geht
es nicht darum dass Menschen die einen
bestimmten Familiennamen tragen aufgrund
der Zugehörigkeit zu einer klaren
Familie oder einer kriminellen klaren
Familie alleine deswegen schon
abgeschoben werden sondern hier geht es
darum Vorschläge zu unterbreiten
inwieweit man hier die Sachlage oder den
dass die Zugehörigkeit zu einem klaren
zu Kriminellen klaren Strukturen eben
polizeilich und justiziell als
kriminelle Vereinigung abzuarbeiten hat
und das soll wiederum dann aufgenommen
werden in die Einschläge gibt Stimmung
des Aufenthaltsgesetzes nämlich dem § 54
wo dann diese Mitgliedschaft in einer
kriminellen Vereinigung oder die
Unterstützung einer kriminellen
Vereinigung dann ausreichend ist um
Menschen eben abzuschieben und da müssen
wir genau in die Tatbestände reinschauen
die kriminelle Vereinigung als solches
ist bereits strafrechtlich relevant wenn
ich nur ihr angehöre das heißt ich muss
keine gesonderten Straftaten begehen
sondern man muss die Polizei die
Strafverfolgungsbehörden müssen hier
nachweisen dass ich eben Angehörige
dieser kriminellen Vereinigung bin also
nochmal hier geht es um die
strafrechtliche Bewertung eines
Verhaltens von Angehörigen krimineller
Clanstrukturen und die geht das nicht um
Genetik oder familienabstammungen darum
geht es nicht der Kampf gegen
organisierte Kriminalität eine riesen
Herausforderung für Beamte und Beamten
hier in Deutschland wir haben einen
Beitrag dazu vorbereitet ein Beitrag von
Christian Volk
eine Großrazzia gegen arabische Clans in
Berlin Wedding das ZDF ist im
vergangenen Jahr exklusiv dabei Verdacht
Drogenhandel im großen Stil etwa 200.000
Mitglieder arabischer Großfamilien gibt
es in Deutschland gegen 930 ermitteln
die Behörden im Zusammenhang mit
organisierter Kriminalität was wirklich
beunruhigend ist meine sind die
Vermögenswerte die wir feststellen dass
eben einzelne kriminelle Clans
mittlerweile wirklich über über
Millionenwerte verfügen die in den
legalen Sektor bringen das ist so eine
Sache wo wir wirklich wachsam sein
müssen als als Polizei aber insgesamt
als Staat und auch unsere Ressourcen
investieren müssen um das zu verhindern
sie will fahrender spielen eine
entscheidende Rolle im Kampf gegen Clan
Kriminalität Olaf B war einer von ihnen
er hat in einem Berliner
brennpunktviertel gearbeitet seinen
Namen haben wir geändert sein Gesicht
zeigen wir nicht
das meiste was in der Clan Kriminalität
abläuft weiß die Öffentlichkeit nicht
die Macht der Großfamilien hat sich mit
Sicherheit vergrößert aus meinen
Erfahrungen kann ich sagen das ist schon
dermaßen organisiert ist und dermaßen
strukturiert ist in dem Bereich dass wir
mit unseren Mitteln eigentlich gar keine
Chance mehr haben und nicht nur
untereinander sein die kriminellen Clans
bestens vernetzt auch in die Polizei
hinein gebe es angeblich gute Kontakte
es gibt Familienangehörige von Clans die
wirklich bei der Berliner Polizei sind
also es ist keine Seltenheit dass wenn
wir einsetzen gekommen sind schon das
Fahrzeug vorher gekannt wurde die
Berliner Polizei spricht von
Einzelfällen
wir haben es gerade gehört also
Einzelfälle die soll es geben wo es
sogar Verbindung von Clans in die
Berliner Berliner Polizei gibt die kann
das sein
also ich würde diese Einzelfälle gerne
mal eine ordentlichen ermittlungsmäßigen
Überprüfung unterziehen wir müssen
natürlich aufpassen dass wir hier nicht
von Angehörigen dieser Familien die
kriminelle Absichten haben hier bei der
Polizei unterwandert werden dann ist
natürlich klar dass wir dem Einhalt
gebieten müssen aber wir haben in den
Einstellungsverfahren bei der deutschen
Polizei natürlich entsprechende
Maßnahmen eingezogen also
Sicherheitsüberprüfungen auch eine
verfassungsschutzrechtliche Überprüfung
die ja nach meinem Dafürhalten bislang
jedenfalls geeignet sein sollte solche
Geschichten zu unterbinden und natürlich
auch im laufenden Betrieb also in dem in
der Arbeit mit diesen Kolleginnen und
Kollegen natürlich eben auch natürlich
eine gewisse Sensibilität da sein muss
aber man sollte jetzt hier nicht den
Fehler machen Menschen die einen
bestimmten Namen tragen denen deswegen
abzusprechen dass sie bei der Polizei
Arbeiten erst dann wenn wir sagen sie
gehören diesen kriminellen Strukturen an
oder unterstützen die diese haben
natürlich müssen diese Leute aus dem
Polizeidienst entfernt werden wie im
übrigen auch alle anderen die eben in
diesem Polizei Straftaten begehen was
wir eben auch noch im Beitrag gehört
haben Millionen schwer und eben immer
machtvoller sollen die Clans sein wieso
kommen wir dann in Deutschland bislang
so wenig dagegen an das ist im Prinzip
das Problem dass diese dass diese
Strukturen diese Kriminellen Familien
eben alles was wir in der deutschen
Rechtsordnung kennen auch auch die
Behördenstrukturen also die Anerkennung
eines eines staatlichen gewaltpotenzials
die Anerkennung einer Gerichtsbarkeit
dass sie die rundweg ablehnen und dass
wir hier im Prinzip die Gefahr haben
dass hier eine Paralleljustiz und eine
Parallelgesellschaft auch etabliert
wurde die ist schon da das stellen wir
fest im Rahmen der Ermittlungen also
hier geht es darum diesen Leuten Einhalt
zu gebieten dass sie uns auf gut deutsch
gesagt nicht mehr auf der Nase rumtanzen
also wir haben hier bereits bei
geringsten polizeilichen Ansätzen alle
einsetzen haben wir hier das Problem
dass innerhalb weniger Sekunden ganze
Familien auf der Straße sind wegen einer
ganz normalen Verkehrskontrolle eines
Angehörigen dieser kriminellen
Clanstrukturen und es dann zu
sogenannten TUM kommt die dazu führen
dass wir mit erheblichen polizeilichen
Einsatzkräften hier an den Tag gehen
müssen um eine Fahrzeugkontrolle
durchzuführen und das denke ich mal kann
nicht sein also wir müssen hier zeigen
dass das einzige Gewaltmonopol was wir
in Deutschland haben eben durch die
Polizeibehörden zum Ausdruck kommt und
nicht durch parallele kriminelle klaren
Strukturen das muss ganz klar sein und
dafür ist im Grunde genommen auch diese
grundsätzliche Intention der
bundesinnenministerin natürlich richtig
ich habe bloß und meine Kolleginnen und
Kollegen in der Praxis haben bloß
Zweifel daran wie man das was dann eben
hier gefordert wird auch tatsächlich
praktisch umsetzen wird
diesen Vorschlag grundsätzlich richtig
ich habe gerade mal geschaut in die
Kommentare im Stream Gilbert grau z.B
schreibt bei Facebook das ist so nicht
möglich denn das widerspricht geltendem
Recht Sippenhaft ist in Deutschland
verboten und wir sprechen mit Herrn
gleich weiter wollen aber jetzt eben auf
diese juristische Debatte eingehen
gemeinsam mit jemand den ich mir noch
dazu eingeladen habe es ist Professor Dr
Daniel Thiem erst Jurist er leitet das
Forschungszentrum aus Länder und
Asylrecht in der Uni Konstanz und ist
jetzt bei uns hallo schönen guten Tag
Herr Professorin guten Abend
gerade gehört ich habe die Kritik von
Gilbert grau einem User bei Facebook
vorgelesen wie ist ihre Einschätzung zu
diesem Vorschlag er spricht oder auch
viele andere Kritik die heute zu hören
war spricht davon Sippenhaft ist in
Deutschland verboten würden Sie sagen
dass es auch ein Vorschlag der ist
einfach gar nicht so umzusetzen
er die Kritik aus dem Chat hat
vollkommen recht aber das liegt auch
daran dass im Gesetzentwurf von der
sittenhaft überhaupt nicht die Rede ist
das heißt da wird in gewisser Weise auf
Windmühlen eingeschlagen da wird so
getan als ob ein Gesetz was drin steht
was gar nicht drin steht und es ist
nicht die Schuld ihres Users sondern es
teilweise auch der Schuld der Medien die
hier jetzt etwas hinein lesen was nicht
drin steht der Begriff der
glänzt zum Beispiel steht in dem
Gesetzentwurf mit keinem Wort drinne
stattdessen ist dort die Rede von der
Mitgliedschaft in der kriminellen
Vereinigung sie haben das eingangs
erwähnt und es ist eindeutig dass eine
große Zugehörigkeit zu einer Familie
nicht ausreicht um in dem Sinne einer
kriminellen Vereinigung anzugehören da
braucht es eine aktive Mitgliedschaften
dazugehören und der Umstand dass ein
Bruder oder auch Cousins Straftaten
begehen oder selber sondern kriminellen
Vereinbarung Vereinigung angehören
reicht nicht aus es braucht eine
Einzelfallprüfung also Sippenhaft wird
es selbst wenn der Gesetzentwurf kommt
so nicht geben
ein weiterer User Kommentar lautet hier
von einem User Userin nennt sich l.ike
bei Youtube na klar ist das gut aber was
sagt das Grundgesetz
das Grundgesetz würde hier icke
vollkommen Recht geben also eine
signhaft dass man Leute dafür mit in
Haftung nimmt was ihre Verwandten tun
dass der mit dem Grundgesetz nicht
vereinbart nur noch mal das steht auch
in dem Gesetzentwurf ihm keinster Weise
drin ist muss in einer Einzelfallprüfung
nachgewiesen werden dass diese Person
einer kriminellen Vereinigung angehört
und nur dann greift dieser neue
Gesetzentwurf und dabei geht es dann
zuerst auch mal nur um die Ausweisung
die Abschiebung ist dann noch mal eine
andere Frage das ist eine nachgelagerte
Sache was man besonders prüfen muss
sehen Sie noch weitere Hürden in diesem
Vorschlag oder ist das jetzt schon der
Hauptkritikpunkt
ja absolut ihr Gast im Studio hat vorhin
kurz mittelbar erwähnt ich meine diese
Clans sind oft schon seit vielen
Jahrzehnten in Deutschland und das führt
dazu dass vor allem die jüngeren
Mitglieder dieser Familien häufig
bereits den deutschen Pass haben und
werden deutschen Pass hat den kann man
auch nach dem neuen Gesetzentwurf nicht
abschieben das ist einfach nicht möglich
das sind Deutsche und die dürfen in
Deutschland leben und zwar unabhängig
davon ob sie noch einen anderen Pass
haben oder nicht und es ist nur ein
Problem es kommt noch was zweites hinzu
es geht bei dem Gesetzentwurf nur um die
Ausweisung und das heißt den Verlust des
Aufenthaltstitels das heißt die Menschen
sind dann wenn er Ausweisung erfolgreich
ist formal rechtswidrig in Deutschland
sie müssen das Land verlassen das heißt
aber noch nicht dass man sie automatisch
abschieben darf ob das der Fall ist oder
nicht muss man besonders prüfen da ist
ein separates Verfahren durchzuführen
und zu kommt dann noch was drin ist auch
nach dem neuen Gesetzentwurf ist so eine
Ausweisung also die Wegnahme des
Aufenthaltstitels die jemand hat nicht
ohne weiteres möglich sondern es braucht
da auch in Zukunft eine umfassen
computerabwägung wo man das Pro und
Contra miteinander abbiegt und da sind
die Gerichte auch sehr streng man muss
berücksichtigen wie lange jemand da lebt
ob er hier Familie hat wie guter
integriert ist da gibt es also überhaupt
kein Automatismus alles was der
Gesetzentwurf sagt ist dass er eben
vorgeht dass bei dieser umfassenden
Einzelfallprüfung Güterabwägung der
Umstand dass meiner kriminellen
Vereinigung angehört etwas mehr wiegt
ausgewiesen und erst recht abgeschoben
wird deswegen niemand automatisch
es gibt auch einige Stimmen bei uns im
Stream die vermuten dass dieser
Vorschlag jetzt nur eine Stimmungsmache
vor der Wahl in Hessen ist mit der Nancy
Ferse auffallen möchte ein User Userin
BK schreibt bei Facebook also ich
behaupte einfach mal frei das ist ein
ungeeigneter Versuch war sich ins
Gespräch zu bringen mehr nicht dass das
so nicht funktioniert sollte gerade ihr
klar sein vermuten sie das auch dass das
eine sehr undurchdachter in dem Falle
Vorschlag war weil eigentlich kommt der
ja tatsächlich wir haben es vorhin schon
angesprochen eben auch von Länder und
Kommunen und auch nicht in erster
Instanz von jetzt dem Innenministerium
ich glaube wir müssen da wirklich zwei
Dinge auseinanderhalten das eine ist der
Gesetzentwurf als solcher der eben auf
diese Beratung auch auf Wünsche vom Bund
und Ländern und Kommunen zurückgeht und
das Frau Feser das jetzt kurz vor dem
Wahlkampf macht das kann man kritisieren
andererseits kritisieren sie auch manche
dafür dass sie so viele Monate gebraucht
hat uns nicht schneller gemacht hat das
ist das eine aber bei dieser ganz
konkreten Vorschrift das jetzt hier die
Ausweisung wohlgemerkt nicht Abschiebung
von Mitgliedern krimineller Vereinigung
etwas erleichtert werden soll da
vermutlich überhaupt keine Strategie
frei Frau Feser weiter in der
öffentlichen Debatte etwas aufgebaut
wird was so in keiner Weise im Gesetz
drin steht und auch ganz sicher nicht
intendiert war also diese Debatte um um
jetzt Kleinkriminalität das ist kein
irgendwie abgekaterte Spiel gewesen weil
ich denke da ist jetzt wirklich welches
zu sagen dafür im Sommer auch etwas
aufgebaut worden was zu groß gar nicht
ist sie haben gerade einen Unterschied
gemacht Ausweisung versus abschie bung
können Sie uns da auch noch mal ganz
konkret sagen was es dabei zu beachten
gilt was ist der Unterschied
Abschiebung das sind Begriffe die
verwendet man verwechselt man sehr
leicht weiß beides irgendwas mit
Verlassen des Landes zu tun hat aber es
sind zwei durchaus unterschiedliche
Dinge Abschiebungen ist der Rhein
tatsächlich Vorgang dass man jemand der
in Deutschland sich bisher aufhält ich
sag mal ganz Platz außer landesschaft
also wegbringt zwangsweise in ein
anderes Land zurückführt das ist die
Abschiebung und die Ausweisung ist das
vorgelagertes da geht es um Menschen die
sich eigentlich rechtmäßig in
Deutschland aufhalten den Männern aber
die Erlaubnis wegnimmt hier zu leben das
nennt man juristisch gesehen die
Ausweisung das ist aber nur der erste
Schritt als nächstes kommt dann die
Abschiebung das ist aber besonders das
Verfahren und diese Ausweisung also die
Wegnahme des Aufenthaltstitels braucht
doch nur dann wenn jemand an sich sich
ja aufhalten darf bei Menschen deren
Asylantrag abgelehnt wird da braucht man
diesen Schritt überhaupt nicht weil wenn
der Asylantrag abgelehnt wird das ja
auch eine Gruppe um die ist vielfach
geht dann darf man ohnehin abschieben
ganz ohne Ausweisung
danke dass Sie das noch mal klarer
gemacht haben aber auf eine Sache würde
ich gerne noch mal eingehen weil sie
sagen vielleicht wird das hier gerade
aufgebaut und Sommerloch schauen wir
vielleicht noch mal rein ich habe es
eingangs in der Sendung schon mal
gemacht schauen wir also noch mal in
dieses Diskussionspapier und hier ich
hatte es vorhin zitiert also an dieser
Stelle steht ja schon ziemlich eindeutig
worum es da geht also es soll eben an
den diese knüpft über den Strafbestand
des Paragraph 129 Strafgesetzbuch
Bildung krimineller Vereinigung an die
Angehörigkeit zu einer solchen solchen
Gemeinschaft an und ist unabhängig von
einer strafrechtlichen Verurteilung da
steht's aber schon ziemlich genau drin
oder genau darum geht wenn die Behörden
nachweisen können und zwar also
strafrechtliche Verurteilung da sind die
Strafgerichte die eine Strafe
aussprechen und in dem Fall geht es
nicht darum auch wenn die strafgerichtet
keine Strafe ausgesprochen haben können
die Ausländerbehörden also andere
Behörden zu dem Ergebnis kommen dass die
Person dennoch einer kriminellen
Vereinigung angehört ohne dass das
bisher rechtlich verfolgt worden wäre
das dürfen Sie sich aber nicht ausdenken
sondern da müssen sie auch Gründe
darlegen und diese Gründe sind im
Zweifelsfall auch vor dem
Verwaltungsgerichten auch wieder andere
Gerichte als Strafgerichte überprüfbar
das heißt wir brauchen nur vorgelagert
keinen strafurtteil welches schon
festgestellt hat dass jemand einer
kriminellen Vereinigung angehört da
müssten ja auch die Ausländerbehörden
gar nichts mehr prüfen dann wäre es ja
schon festgestellt sondern auch wenn wir
kein strafurtteil haben dürfen die
Ausländerbehörden des eigenständig
prüfen müssen das dann aber auch
darlegen wie gesagt wenn im Zweifelsfall
wird das von den Gerichten überprüft und
das zeigt Ihnen auch das ist alles fest
in den Rechtsstaat
eingerichtet und auch um noch mal eine
andere Sache ganz klar zu machen was
schon auch vom der Sprecherin des
Ministeriums auf Nachfrage der
Süddeutschen Zeitung bestätigt wurde
also es geht hier schon auch ganz klar
um Angehörige sogenannter Clanstrukturen
das hat sie so gesagt also es geht darum
Angehörigen sogenannter Clanstrukturen
um die künftig leichter abschieben zu
können also meint das Innenministerium
ja doch ganz klar klar richtig
genau aber wenn das Innenministerium
meinte das mit diesem Gesetzentwurf alle
Mitglieder dieser sogenannten Clans
einfach aus der Landes geschafft werden
dürfen dann würde es irren dann hätte es
hier etwas vorgeschlagen was sozusagen
die Juristen formulierenden untauglicher
Versuch ist das Ziel was man da
politisch essen will hat würde mit dem
Gesetzentwurf jedenfalls überhaupt nicht
erreicht werden bei der steht da
schlichtweg nicht drinne wir brauchen im
Einzelfall nachweisbar eine
Zugehörigkeit zu einer kriminellen
Vereinigung und die bloße Verwandtschaft
dass man Brüder Cousins hat die im
größeren Umfang Straftaten begehen ist
für sich genommen ganz garantiert nichts
was die Behörden und erst rechtliche
Gerichte anerkennen würden als etwas was
in dem Sinne eine Ausweisung
rechtfertigt ganz abgesehen davon dass
man da noch all die zusätzlichen
Prüfungspunkte hatte ich vorher erwähnt
habe also wenn das Ministerium meint mit
dem Gesetzentwurf wirklich alle
Mitglieder von klangfamilien abschieben
zu dürfen dann hätten sie sich nicht weg
geirrte steht dort nicht drin sagt
Professor Dr Daniel Typ vielen Dank für
Ihre Einschätzung dass sie das für uns
geklärt haben und bei uns zu Gast waren
danke Ihnen
jetzt ist wieder Zeit noch mehr Zeit für
eure Fragen an Dirk pecklo er ist noch
weiter bei uns erst der Vorsitzende des
Bundes Deutscher Kriminalbeamter und
eine Frage im Stream die habe ich
gesehen die passt sehr gut zu dem was
her Professor Thiem gerade gesagt hat es
geht darum nachzuweisen natürlich auch
was passiert ist und es gibt eine Frage
von einem User eine Userin die fragt
sich wie kann die Polizei die
Angehörigkeit zu jemanden der nach
kriminellen Vereinigung ist überhaupt
beweisen
na vielleicht sollten wir mal nach
Italien schauen also wir haben ja in
Italien schon seit langer Zeit eben
bestimmte Tatbestände dort nennt man das
Mitgliedschaft in einer Vereinigung nach
Art der Mafia und da ist es eben schon
sehr schnell passiert dass man eben
einer kriminellen Vereinigung wieder
Mafia zugerechnet wird das könnte man
auch adaptieren für die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland für unsere Gesetzgebung für
unsere Strafrechtspraxis indem man z.B
sagt wir haben im 129 also in dem
Tatbestand kriminelle also
Mitgliedschaft Bildung einer kriminellen
Vereinigung auch noch einen Absatz in
dem es geregelt ist das auch die
Unterstützung einer kriminellen
Vereinigung oder das Verben für eine
kriminelle Vereinigung unter Strafe
gestellt ist das heißt wir könnten hier
durchaus mal darüber nachdenken dass wir
jetzt einerseits das hat ist eben nicht
gesagt worden dass wir eben endlich mal
diese Verfahren gegen kriminelle klar
Strukturen mal unter dem Arbeitstitel
kriminelle Vereinigung führen und zwar
ein Absprache auch mit den zuständigen
Dezernentinnen in der Staatsanwaltschaft
also das ist der erste Schritt den wir
hier benötigen und dass wir dann wenn
wir das machen wenn wir also mal die
Prüfung aufstellen ist das denn eine
kriminelle Vereinigung um dies hier geht
und ich bin habe überhaupt keine Zweifel
dass wir das in vielen Bereichen der
Kleinkriminalität haben dass wir davon
eine kriminellen Vereinigung sprechen
müssen dass wir dann natürlich auch über
den anderen Absatz des § 129
Möglichkeiten haben zum Beispiel
unterstützungshandlungen also wenn dann
eben Angehörige von planfamilien bei
tumult-delikten wie zum Beispiel
Verkehrskontrollen wo sie eben deutlich
machen dass sie diese Kriminellen
planstrukturen unterstützen dass sie mit
ihrem Namen der diese Kriminellen
klarstruktur zuzurechnen ist eben
Stimmung machen gegen die entsprechenden
vollzugskräfte der Polizei dass das eben
dann reichen kann anzunehmen dass hier
eine kriminelle Vereinigung im Sinne
einer kriminelle einer kriminellen
klaren Struktur eben von dieser Person
unterstützt wird und dann sind wir
schnell dabei dass wir eben dann prüfen
müssen das ist dann nämlich das
Verhalten was diese Person zeigt was
eben zum Ausdruck bringt das kann durch
polizeiliche Ermittlungen belegt werden
das sieht diese kriminelle Vereinigung
nämlich den Kriminellen Clan hier
unterstützt durch diese Handlung ohne
selbst Mitglied zu sein das ist das
entscheidende also wir müssen einfach
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen die in
diesen Bereichen arbeiten es ist sehr
wichtig dass wir hier
strukturermittlungen führen dass wir
also feststellen polizeilich feststellen
wem müssen wir dem kriminellen Milieu
eines Clans zurechnen dass wir natürlich
dann auch im zweiten Schritt feststellen
welche Arten von Straftaten werden hier
begangen es geht ja nicht nur immer um
schwere Delikte sondern auch um Bereiche
der Alltagskriminalität aber in einem
hohen Maß wir reden auch von
Ordnungswidrigkeiten die hier
verwirklicht werden das heißt wir müssen
alle umfassend mit verschiedenen
Behördenstrukturen sowie das z.B auch in
Nordrhein-Westfalen den Teilen schon
umgesetzt worden ist müssen wir eben
gegen diese kriminellen Strukturen
vorgehen und zwar unter dem Arbeitstitel
Bildung oder Mitgliedschaft in einer
kriminellen Vereinigung ich glaube das
ist der Schlüssel und ich glaube das ist
auch was man jetzt hier bei diesem
vorgelegten Diskussionspapier mitnehmen
muss dass wir in Deutschland diesen
Schritt gehen müssen analog dem Schritt
den die italienischen
Verfolgungsbehörden schon seit vielen
vielen Jahren gehen was aber natürlich
an diesem wir hatten es auch schon ist
klang schon mal an in der Sendung was an
diesem Vorschlag schwierig wird das
stellt ja auch User Sven Odendahl bei
Facebook fest stellt sich hier nicht
dasselbe Problem wie bei anderen
Abschiebungen nämlich dass die
Heimatländer diese Personen nicht
zurücknehmen wollen das ist ein Punkt
und ein anderer Punkt den ich noch
gelesen habe war von echoloss 1907 bei
Youtube das ist doch und durchführbar es
sind doch alle Staatenlose bzw deutsche
Staatsbürger die können nicht
abgeschoben werden schauen wir mal in
die Zahlen wir haben auch hier Zahlen
vorliegen und zwar geht es hier um die
Verfahren in der organisierten
Kriminalität es sind wohl 47 hier an der
Zahl Verfahren die es im digitalen sind
von 2021 gab und wenn man hier weiter
runter schaut und die Zahlen weiter
aufschlüsselt ist ja auch die
Staatsangehörigkeit angegeben für
2021/20 hier sehen wir es also türkisch
Deutsch libanesische staatenlos und so
weiter und so fort
Frage an Sie jetzt mal zurückgespielt
Herr peglo was der User da geschrieben
hat der einfach sagte das ist doch
schwierig weil das sind doch alles
deutsche Staatsbürger im Zweifel oder
viele sind deutsche Staatsbürger sagen
wir es mal so das ist wohl eine
Problematik die wird sich dann auch
damit nicht lösen lassen natürlich
sofern sie nur die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft haben wird sich diese
Problematik nicht lösen lassen weil wir
natürlich keine deutschen
Staatsangehörigen abschieben können die
andere Frage und das war ja auch
Grundlage der der Konferenz der
Regierungschefs und Chefin der der
Bundesländer mit der mit dem
Bundeskanzler dass wir bei der bei dem
Thema Abschiebung eben generell
festgestellt haben dass es viele
Probleme gibt dass wir die Fragestellung
haben wir ein Vollzugsdefizit oder haben
wir einen regelungsdefiziert ich denke
wir haben ehrenvollzugsdefizit aber wir
haben auch ein diplomatisches Problem
weil wir natürlich und das hat die
Bundesregierung ja auch erkannt dass wir
eben Länder haben die ihre Leute
schlicht und ergreifen erstens nicht
zurücknehmen zweitens wir nachweisen
müssen dass das die Staatsangehörigen
dieses Landes also dieses dass wir das
Herkunftsland eben nachweisen müssen und
das müssen wir auch mal die
terroristische Vereinigung ist auch eine
Vereinigung wo bereits die
Mitgliedschaft das unterstützen strafbar
ist und auch hier stellen wir ja wenn es
um das Thema Abschiebung geht fest meine
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die in diesem
Bereich arbeiten dass wir selbst bei
erkannten Straftätern bei erkannten
islamistisch orientierten Terroristen
und Terroristen dass wir da ein Problem
haben diese abzuschieben wenn sie eben
aus Ländern kommen wo sie dann wo klar
ist dass sie verfolgt werden dann haben
wir nämlich an sogenanntes
Abschiebungshindernis dass uns eben in
die nicht in die Lage versetzt dort was
zu machen also hier ist einerseits
Diplomatie gefragt das ist eine Frage
des Auswärtigen Amtes das mit den
Ländern reden muss wo wir einfach nicht
weiterkommen und es gibt natürlich auch
Länder wo schlichten ergreifen überhaupt
keine Möglichkeit besteht abzuschieben
da haben wir ein Abschiebestopp Punkt
aus Feierabend so das gehört auch zu
Wahrheit dazu und deswegen ist es in der
polizeilichen Praxis wird so ein
Vorschlag natürlich wenn es darum geht
wir wollen jetzt hier mehr abschieben im
Bereich der Clank Kriminalität
wird in Teilbereichen bei meinen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen da müde darüber
gelächelt weil die tägliche Praxis beim
Thema Abschiebung eben uns zeigt dass
wir da eigentlich nicht hinterherkommen
in der Form wie wir es gerne hätten es
wird auch immer wieder ich muss es
nochmal aufgreifen bei uns im Chat
vermutet das ist vielleicht jetzt hier
auch eine Politik mache die da passiert
ist gab eben auch Kritik zum Beispiel
von der stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden
der Unionsfraktion Andrea Lindholz die
hatte auch juristische Bedenken geäußert
kritik kam ich habe es gesagt sowohl vor
auch von der SPD von den Grünen die
selbst im Mitglied in der CDU und jetzt
haben wir hier eine eine kommentar von
Simon Feldkamp bei Youtube er schreibt
ist die Ausrichtung dieser härteren
Gangart in der Politik eine versuchte
Antwort auf die zuwechse der AFD was
wäre da ihre Vermutung sie bekommen es
ja eben ganz aktiv in der Praxis mit sie
bekommen auch die politische Diskussion
mit ihrem Meinung dazu also persönliche
Motivationslage von Frau Feser im
Hinblick auf den Wahlkampf in Hessen
kann ich nichts sagen das wäre sehr viel
Unterstellung oder Mutmaßungen aber eins
muss man sagen diese Forderung ist
leider nicht geboren bei Frau Feser oder
im BMI also im Bundesinnenministerium
sondern das ist alles zurückzuführen auf
die Konferenz der Ministerpräsidenten
Ministerpräsidenten mit den
Bundeskanzler so und es ist
zurückzuführen auf hatte ich vorhin
schon mal gesagt den Koalitionsvertrag
in dem eben drin steht dass wir die
organisierte dass die Bundesregierung
die Bekämpfung der organisierten
Kriminalität insbesondere auch der Clan
Kriminalität mehr fokussieren will in
den Mittelpunkt der Betrachtung rücken
will neben anderen Dingen auch aber hier
haben wir ein Schwerpunkt festgestellt
so jetzt ist das was Herr Thum auch
schon mal gesagt hat dass jetzt
natürlich die Fragestellung ist wie
gehen wir jetzt damit um das ist es ist
ja eine diskussions-papier das heißt
wenn das als Gesetzentwurf vorgelegt
wird wird ein ordentliches
stellungnahmeverfahren geben es wird ein
Ressort Abstimmung geben wir werden auch
entsprechend die verschiedenen
Expertinnen und Experten werden sich
dazu äußern und das ist der Zeitpunkt wo
wir dann genau drauf schauen werden wo
wir uns mit unseren Kolleginnen und
Kollegen ins Benehmen setzen werden und
werden die Hinweise aus der Praxis
mitnehmen unsere Aufgabe als Bund
Deutscher Kriminalbeamter ist es weniger
juristische die Fragestellung zu
diskutieren auch das aber unsere Aufgabe
ist es in erster Linie denn
Politikerinnen und Politikern oder den
Mitgliedern des jeweiligen Ausschusses
in dem das besprochen wird klar zu
machen was diese Umsetzung wenn es denn
gesetzt wird für die polizeiliche Praxis
bedeutet und wenn wir dann
Schwachstellen erkennen bei der
polizeilichen Arbeit die aufgrund nicht
vorhandener gesetzlicher Regelung eben
zu Tage treten dann ist es Aufgabe der
Verantwortlichen Politikerinnen und
Politiker dass der Bevölkerung zu
erklären das ist nicht meine Aufgabe
meiner Aufgabe kann nur sein zu sagen
was ein Gesetz für Konsequenzen für das
polizeiliche arbeiten hat und zum
Schluss dann auch gerne die Frage an Sie
Ihr Hinweis aus der Praxis was würde was
woran fehlt es ihnen am allermeisten was
macht das so schwer gegen klaren
Kriminalität gegen kriminelle
Vereinigung anzukommen also wir müssen
einfach mal erstmal eine einheitliche
Bekämpfungsstrategie haben da ist man
dran also wir haben mittlerweile glaube
ich schon eine Situation dass wir und
das ist gut erkannt haben dass wir mit
Clank Kriminalität ein Problem haben in
Deutschland ist da glaube ich mal
zitiert worden mit der Sache wir haben
20 Jahre verpennt so hat er sich glaube
ich dazu geäußert und das würde ich auch
so unterschreiben wir haben über viele
viele Jahre eben das Problem schon sehr
früh zwar erkannt in der Fachlichkeit
aber in der politischen
Verantwortlichkeit haben es nicht
angegangen jetzt machen wir das aber
eben nicht nur durch die viel berühmten
1000 Nadelstiche sondern wir müssen
kriminalpolizeiliche Kompetenzen wir
müssen Personal haben sowohl bei der
Kriminalpolizei als auch natürlich bei
der Justiz bei der Staatsanwaltschaft
die diese sehr umfangreichen auch sehr
lange dauernden Ermittlungsverfahren
führen können einerseits aber auch die
Zeit dafür haben das zu tun also das ist
keine Sache die man im Leben macht
sondern hier brauchen wir Profis die
wissen wie man taktisch auch rechtlich
in solchen Ermittlungsverfahren an den
Amts Tagewerk geht sagt er ist
Vorsitzender des bundesdeutsche
Kriminalbeamter und heute bei uns zu
Gast gewesen vielen Dank herzlichen Dank
und danke auch an euch natürlich für
eure Zeit für die Diskussion ihr könnt
auch jetzt gerne natürlich noch weiter
im Nachlauf im Chat diskutieren tauscht
euch aus wie Ihr diesen Vorschlag findet
und seid gerne das nächste Mal wieder
dabei bis dahin tschüss